bonjour Como Italian
Emily in Paris
[Applause]
[Applause]
yellow a beret Bienvenu we have a very
special Emily in Paris show our entire
audience is filled with super fans
and one lucky audience member here today
will have the chance to win a trip to
Paris
[Applause]
season three Netflix Premiere which
takes place December 21st but first
let's catch up
um all of us with this love letter to
one of the buzziest most important
delightful effervescent delicious and
wonderful shows out there Emily in Paris
roll the tape
romance French cuisine and some of the
best talent on TV well then you've got
Emily in Paris in 2020 58 million
households said bonjour to Netflix's hit
show following social media Savvy Emily
Cooper on a Grand Adventure through the
city of love leaving behind your life
and boyfriend in Chicago Emily joins a
Parisian Marketing Group doing her best
to impress clients and win over her
co-workers despite not knowing a lick of
French the show has been such a hit it's
been nominated for Golden Globes and
Emmys it's no surprise since the brain
behind the show is the same brain that
brought us Sex in the City Mr Darren
Starr the only thing in this show higher
than the heels are the feels between the
friendships office drama and steamy
romances the incredible cast of American
and French Talent completely and
absolutely delivers season three is just
around the corner so grab a bag that
pick up some fromage and let's hit that
sofa because we say we and yes to Emily
in Perry or Paris and if you have yet to
embrace the show well get to it because
there's no better day than today to
start binging this is the show everybody
loves and we can't wait for more
Lily Collins
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
oh
my God you guys I can't believe it I'm
having the most surreal moment right now
I mean Lily you've gotten married you
were in yeah
great yeah I'm married now and and
Charlie and our little dog Redford get
to come on set and have been in Paris
for the three years uh and it's it's
wonderful great I'm so happy
you really deserve all the happiness in
the world you're such a kind and good
person it's like oh good good things
happen to good people and Philippine is
it true that initially maybe you the
casting director weren't certain about
the role like was there an you know it
wasn't me they had written the part for
somebody that was 35 40 years old I was
obviously much too old for the part
[Applause]
like to be that sexy in life oh my gosh
what is it like no I'm not I'm totally
not as sexy as Sylvie I mean do you have
confidence like her I do
how can you give us some tips on
confidence uh just know who you are the
beauty comes from inside a certain age
you just let go a lot of things
I know I love it and Ashley what's going
on in your life like what do you mean
I'm on the drier Marshall with my
friends and my cats are you happy are
things going well for you and also
um like I heard something that your
celebrity crush when you were younger
might have been Aladdin and Simba yeah
both my first crush was a cartoon lion
so that was fun for me
my first question was Darth Vader wow is
he wasn't available
did you have a childhood Crush uh
I don't know I have no memory of this
I was so into uh soccer and drawings and
I was I wasn't interested in anything uh
or anyone and yet I heard that you are
one of the men who appreciated sex in
the city is this true I didn't
appreciate it it was my guide through
childhood and puberty you know wow yeah
I I there are things your parents don't
tell you and and when you see Sex in the
City you're like oh oh oh oh
no well thank you Darren right yeah
right
I'd love to bring out the rest of the
cast actually will you please welcome
Samuel Arnold Bruno guerri
William abadi and Lucian lava Scout
s
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
ER I have to admit I tried to guess I
didn't guess the right person so whoever
it is will you fess up please
um I guess that's me
oh
yeah
Monopoly Deal but she's the gamer yeah
how did it start
um you know I'm from a small town in a
Countryside of South France so it was
pretty lonely and so video game for me
was an escape and I started at 13. and
Samuel um you said that like filming the
show sort of helped you like ReDiscover
Paris because you're living in London
now yes I do I do and uh no it's just
the fact that I think when you're local
you don't really know your city you
don't go to all those tourists touristic
spots and I felt like Ashley would take
me to places in Paris and I'll be like
whoa I didn't know that that place now
speaking of cities
um I just spent a lot of time
um in Sicily with you Bruno because oh
my God how are you in every important
show right now
fly on the wall moment what was it like
you know to do that show it was amazing
and I remember a story at the end you
know the grand finale I am in a very bad
position at the end
you remember and Mike would say to me
Bruno this is not even in Paris right
now William you were in Sex in the City
and and just like that and Emily in
Paris so
yeah
um are you friends with Darren Starr and
like by the way you were also in an
episode that really like screwed me up
with sex in the city because it's the
episode where Carrie buys Burger the
Prada shirt then he has to prove his
manhood and then he leaves her on the
red carpet and it just oh God that
episode
been there that episode and that red
shirts are are pursuing me in the most
beautiful way I mean it's it's uh I
almost get more recognition from one
little appearance on on Sex in the City
20 years ago than I do on Emily in Paris
being you know a little bit of a a main
character yeah yeah yeah foreign
is it true that when you were that you
were discovered by David Beckham and and
his team were you with your mom that's
my mom I was about 10 years old and um I
had a big afro and I really had I was a
little bit cocky
um and I was trying up the shop
attendant and a woman overheard I
probably gonna go say like I'm we're
gonna go we're gonna go watch Lion King
I'll be your Darth Vader by the way
whenever you need but anyway
[Applause]
who's your childhood fantasy out of
curiosity I'm living living the dream
right now
[Applause]
this has never happened to me
what did you do again I'm like okay so
you were saying you met David Beckham's
agent in a in an apartment store no I I
go I go I got asked to do a casting for
um uh marks and Spencer's which was um
it's like a clothing oh I know Mark
since Spencer I'm actually wearing their
underwear right now
[Applause]
for Marks and Spencer those are the two
underwear I wear can we really cut to
that commercial break
this is kind of like your show that's
how I feel when I'm watching it like it
keeps you on your toes and now you're
Emily welcome to my world
and I have to say like I've been
watching I've had the privilege of
getting a peek you know through the
keyhole into season three and I'm loving
it so much
ciao
and in honor of the incredible style of
the show we actually have an Emily and
Paris Super Fan who got a Trey Chic
makeover and she got an Emily in Paris
redo if you will will you stick around
for the big reveal okay we'll be right
back
[Applause]
million Paris Extravaganza I'm here with
the incredible ladies of the cast and I
have to say the fashion is just
incredible this is one of the first
shows since a Sex in the City where it
is a Runway of a show I'm always looking
forward to what everybody's wearing and
we asked a viewer it's true thank you we
asked a viewer who came to us asking how
to get that Emily in Paris look ah let's
take a look hi crew my name is Michelle
and I'm a mom to a beautiful beautiful
two-year-old daughter and I've been
teaching high school now for 25 years
it's so hard to find any time for myself
but when I do I love watching Emily in
Paris and every time I try to put it
together I look like Emily I can't do it
so if you could help me put a look
together to look like Emily I would love
it
[Music]
[Applause]
we're gonna look at her you know before
picture and here is post Emily in Paris
magic mom Michelle come on
[Applause]
okay
that's beautiful thank you look at you
and do you mind if we see like uh the
whole look yes yes in fact here take
this and we celebrated Viva magenta
which is the Pantone color of the year
and this is sort of an electric version
of that and also when you go with a
monochromatic look because you're not
blocking anything up it elongates the
look it does hot tip yes and I love the
bow it's like it's a little gift to
yourself yeah and you know and and is
beautiful too like it really just brings
out you which I love you're wearing the
outfit and also you're really a gift to
so many people because you're a teacher
and like really thank you
thank you we get to celebrate
um we get to celebrate happiness on our
show and positivity but you get to do
that every single day with your students
and that's like the biggest gift of all
so thank you
do you feel like how do you feel I feel
great I feel like I just stepped off the
set of Emeline
well Mercy Michelle a echo Lily
sentiment about thank you for everything
you do and being a mom is you know it's
the greatest gift in the world but
teaching is the gift that really
just so many other people thank you for
everything you do all right when we come
back Emily might not be the only one in
the city of love because a member of our
audience is going to leave here
to a trip to Paris that's right
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back I am with the entire cast
of Emily in Paris the dream is real and
we have about one minute left
and we wanted to uh put one of our super
fans to the test in a game we like to
call usually Pop Quiz but this is Le pop
quiz yeah we went there you know uh
where is Rebecca Lytle Rebecca are you
[Applause]
oh my God this is perfect oh my God
if you get these three questions right
you will win an all expenses paid trip
to the city of love and life
all right here we go
um I am going to
um ask
um if I may dare say my new friends
um to ask the questions at William what
is the name of the marketing firm Emily
Sylvie Julia and Luke workout
oh my God
[Applause]
Lucas that's the next one wait can I can
I can I hug her can I touch it
[Applause]
so what famous Parisian Landmark is a
charm on Emily's purse take your time
[Applause]
last one oh my God I feel like a lot of
pressure now oh my God gotta tell you
you are so hot
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay name two people up here whose
characters are not involved in a love
triangle square
or Affair that's a tough one
Mendy I would say Julian
and baby Luke even though they do that
Eiffel Tower
[Applause]
you did it thank God because I was about
to throw up
[Applause]
thank you to Trip Advisor
You've Won your curated traveler's
Choice best of the best trip to two for
two to Paris valued at ten thousand
dollars
[Music]
[Applause]
Parisian experience
that's right you're gonna get a guided
tour of the Louvre you're going to
explore the city of love on Segways like
in the show all meals are paid for it is
now Rebecca in Paris
but my greatest thing uh to the entire
cast of Emily in Paris because season
three drops globally on Netflix on
December 21st
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my goodness sorry for that accent but
I the intention is good we're
celebrating season three of Emily in
Paris with the entire cast and an
audience full of super fans including
myself and Ross obviously Ross and I are
actually going to turn the mic over to
them for their burning questions in a
Drew and a Emily in Paris Edition
[Applause]
that's right okay first up Trisha what
is your first question so my question is
do you guys have a cast group text and
if so what's the last thing you guys
talked about we've been asked that a lot
I think we need to start one now I think
we have like five going simultaneously
but there's different yeah there's no
like also it's hard because there's a
lot of overseas like I never know what
phone anyone's using the WhatsApp the
French number the British numbers you
know and there's always that Android
User also
screws up the group chat because they
can't be on it
um and I'm sure in your case with the
whatsapps and the Androids it must be
hard to group text that that's just a
logistical issue
you have four phones
why do you have four phones
you know I mean are we going to get all
four phone numbers just asking
all right Ross you have someone to ask a
burning Emily and Paris family question
oh we we yes I do okay this is Kelsey
say hi say bonjour bonjour what's your
question
who who is the most like their character
in real life and who is the least like
their character oh good question
least like their character yes yeah I
would say that too yeah I think yeah
[Applause]
always uh you know actors that are a bit
close to the the character and then then
of course it's not us but there's always
a part of us in it so we're all pretty
not similar but there's a big part of us
in in our characters and do you think
that like he writes also continuously
does he you know continue to grow
characters in the story that he sees fit
and needs to build but like pulls little
intricacies maybe from you yes totally
totally he lives with us and he writes
as sometimes he's going to see things
that happens with us uh uh outside of
said and he's gonna put it in the script
we're lucky enough to have our writers
also most of them live in Paris while
we're filming and so they've gotten to
know little isms and such especially
between us and there's so many scenes
that sometimes we find ourselves
questioning whether or not we had
already had that conversation a week
prior because we'd all you know what I
mean like
yeah the conversations are so genuine
and real between all of us on the show
that we've pretty much already had them
and then they get written in and it just
feels just so much like our voice and
they've it's grown from season one to
season two to season three and we just
get so much collaboration and input
which is the best because then it really
feels real that might attribute to like
the magic of the chemistry of the show
too it is really exciting
um you know when I'm on your guys's side
of things I love when writers pick up
you know nuances of conversations or you
know if you play with your friend's hair
all of a sudden they'll write that into
the scene and you know it's like it's
like you're being watched but in a good
way this time you know it's not like is
there someone peeping at me in that tree
that's creepy it's like oh someone's
picking up you know those cool little
isms that we do and contributing it to
the creativity and the authenticity of
the show I'm so glad to know that that's
such a fly on the wall
um all right uh Ashley
um hello oh my God so fun you know I've
never been up here this is like the
first time I'm getting my Phil Donahue
on and I'm really excited so thank you
for a first Ashley what is your question
Hi Cass hi
there's a lot of fun flirting throughout
the show so I'm wondering in real life
do you guys have any
um pick up lines that you guys like to
use or moves oh oh
I have one
um uh are you from Paris because uh I
feel for you oh
I feel a pain I love that you just said
that that was it it probably does you
know because you're cute and you get
away with it
um well I've seen some flirting here
today so I think you know I think it is
it is possible uh but yes I mean I I'm
I'm curious does anyone have a another
good pickup line I mean I don't even
know what to say I'm so Rusty do you
understand not what
do you have a good pickup line pick up
line like when you're hitting on someone
and you're like oh you're hot and then
like in the French way French word no
just talking with that voice
thank you
as he crosses his leg with his Louboutin
shoe Ross he goes have you heard a White
Lotus and Emily in Paris exactly that'll
work every time I'm here with Michelle
now Michelle say hi to everybody
all right what's your question I love
the love triangles on the phone on the
show I have to ask who do you think is
Emily's end game
wait until you watch this season because
wow right when you think you know what's
gonna happen the finale happens and then
geometry starts all over again
geometry classes in session this year
and I'll tell you that much
I love it
Peter I want and need more okay we have
to go to a quick commercial break but
I'm just loving these questions we have
more passionate super fan questions
right when we come back I want to hear
all the answers I'm learning so much
[Music]
all right we are back with the entire
cast of Emily in Paris up next is Tracy
what Saucy questions do you have up your
sleeve
well hi everybody hi Tracy my question
is what is the biggest difference of
dating in France versus in America are
the French better at kissing
hence French kissing yes
well I'm married so I'm going to tap out
we don't really date in France
what does that mean
we don't have a label for it it's it's
uh it's a bit more of an organic thing
that is what it is without true putting
a stamp on oh my God American women
would lose their minds they know
everything totally like our French women
just more easy going with that type of
um
it doesn't mean that doesn't mean that
no no it just means that we don't have
the dating thing it's like we go out if
we like each other or you know we can go
wherever we want it's not like we're
gonna wait for the second phone call the
third phone call that kind of exactly
you know that coded thing that you have
do you think that women in France like
if they want to call someone they'll
just call them they won't overthink and
talk to your friends obsessed freak out
like lose their minds analyze every word
it's helpful with the expectations
expectations of the mother of deformity
my father used to say that but if you
met my father you'd understand he
couldn't he was incapable of having any
expectations put on him don't get me
started on relationship
all right this is not about that but uh
but I Do by the way I love French
kissing I wish I knew the origin of
where that term comes from from France
well then you do do kissing better
you know French kissing is the best okay
Rossi take it away oh this is riveting I
gotta say uh we're all having so much
fun over here and by the way we're all
obsessing over your outfits right thank
you for showing up today you did not
disappoint each and every one of you I
know it's like this show come to life
Gorge Gorge and uh with so many
questions Mary has one for you right now
hit it hi everyone Hi
um what is the best and worst things a
tourist can do while visiting in Paris
oh that's a great question because there
are don'ts I know because I see the
Expressions
okay the worst thing a tourist can do in
Paris is to expect everyone to speak
English oh yeah
the parisians hate that make a little
effort try to learn at least a few words
you know yeah if they want to speak
English we saw that in episode one right
when Emily showed up I learned the hard
way yes
and also don't take a cab at 5 00 PM
because it's traffic jam so don't do
that you will lose your money honestly I
like french kissing I hate traffic there
you go but it's a Hot Topic you could
probably do a little more French kissing
if you had the person well then I guess
the traffic wouldn't be so bad you're
right
that's nice to eat right yeah yeah
it's just so good no no you're right
actually get used to scootering because
that's really fun like if you don't want
to be stuck in traffic like Scooters or
bicycles get it gets you have a good
plan of the land yeah we're really into
Transportation mode
I am so here for it wear flats not
always heels because those cobblestone
streets will get you yeah
don't wear stilettos on the Cobblestone
it's so true I I do watch the show
thinking about that I'm like that those
shoes would be hard and I thought about
it with sex in the city too they were
always in heels I'm like have you walked
up and down Manhattan and you would be
your your ankles would be chafed within
an inch of their life
um okay our final question comes from
Matt what is your question Matt oh
[Applause]
thank you
16 years of French right there
um my question is in season one there
was a scene where some deep dish pizza
got some Flack have you guys actually
had it do you love it what are your
Vibes with it never try yeah never never
tried never tried
well it's funny because
um you know you as Emily mentioned a Lou
Malnati's you had an exchange with them
in real life it was so sweet and dear
they love you and the show and our
friends over at Lou Malnati's actually
had a special message for the cast and
we're going to do a deep dish dive into
it come right back
foreign
[Applause]
cast of Emily in Paris now in the first
season Emily moves from uh she moves to
Paris but from Chicago and it is home of
the deep dish pizza and there was a bit
of a kerfuffer regarding a joke at Lou
Malnati's expense they're actually one
of the most accoladed and respected pie
companies and they had a little special
message for you A big hello to the cast
of Emily in Paris it's Mark Malnati the
owner of Lou Malnati's Pizzeria in
Chicago and I know we got off to a
little bit of a rough start but it was
all in good fun today to celebrate your
third season I'm sending you each your
very own deep dish Chicago Pizza a
little treat from The Windy City for you
[Applause]
well I mean I don't know about you guys
but Pizza is definitely a healing thing
for me and a good medicine
um Samuel and Bruno have you guys I have
any of you had deep dish I mean I you
know I feel like us American girls duh
not to sound like a cliche but are you
guys deep dishers
we're about to be all right yes I've
never had it either and I live here what
do you think uh I'm not a deep disher
it's the first time I see a deep dish
pizza
well I'm excited would you like to taste
and see what it is
[Applause]
oh my God
it's so good I was very hungry oh my God
thank you okay I regret
being you know such a
spoiler with this I mean this is great
it is and I'm sorry you know I mean
Silly's been horrible to this pizza
well thank you
this reminds me I'll be back I'll be
back we have we have the crap you have
the pancake we in Europe mostly have a
thin crust this is like the crust is
amazing it's very good we have thin
crushed too but this is you know an
absolute Chicago American classic and
Illuminati's is so good I mean this is
delicious and I like to motorboat my
food I'm never gonna be like that girl
who was like you know
and pretty I'm like ah
let's go
like a pie for us you know but it's
delicious wait have you guys had a New
York slice the newcomers the New York
yeah have you had a New York slices yes
I did where
um in uh Broadway the first time when I
came to New York to see Ashley
performing two years ago at my New York
I saw Ashley perform yesterday
[Applause]
[Music]
Pizza
I love uh Joe's Pizza in New York that
one is like the ultimate slice but is
there a French food that sort of gets
Flack but really we should take a second
look at it and it's fantastic so for us
Americans well a very good [ __ ] Monsieur
right what's not to like about a croque
Monsieur or Madame or Madame but like
I'm an egg on top I've never had escar
go yeah good in Paris you know what
funny thing this is the reaction I'm
looking for yeah we were shooting it
made me want to try it it's very good we
were trying
um with Ashley for her first time we're
at the restaurant and she and she was
like I'm not going to try that I'm like
babe just try it and she was like
oh my God that's delicious I put a lot
of butter it's a lot of butter but
what's the texture like I mean I don't
even want to tell you what they look
like it's not the best part really I
like the texture it's more the process
that's fun you have the Little Fork and
the little tongs and you're like and
then you pretty woman and throw it and
they say slippery little suckers all the
time
I should I try escargot you have to yeah
yes okay
what is that the yeah is that the next
cord
unfortunately it's not I didn't think of
that but when we come back as our last
segment we're going to give you a super
tease of Emily in Paris season three and
that should be just a tasty and anything
out there we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
for one year oh gosh welcome back it is
time for excuse me I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry I love that I love that
[Applause]
oh my God filthy Philippine is saying
she loves me I love you okay well it is
time for in a minute excuse him while
um or should I say
thank you this is why I get those looks
in Paris I'm here with the cast of Emily
in Paris and before we go we wanted to
give you a sneak peek at the new season
may I just say it is Trey manifique
take a look no problemo where you go
I'm loyal to you Emily
okay guys have a nice day
bye
okay new plan maybe you can make it pact
with Cami not to tell Madeline you're
quitting and you'll be out of a job at
lunch time I guess Savannah just arrived
oh
my God
now that is insane I've never seen you
this excited and it's over a car come on
put me in coach you don't even
understand the menu um don't anymore but
my French has gotten Trey better
hey Louie Mindy
I mean it's not worse I'm so in on team
whatever this company's called you can
help us choose I like using it means SAS
Factory no something more heroic you
know
The Gatekeepers what I need from you is
a sexy new client in the luxury space to
pair with the launch I have just the
thing McDonald's
foreign
[Applause]
just continuing to ascend I wanted to
thank everyone so much for coming here I
I said in the break and I'll say it
again you guys have made the world a
better place you've made people happy at
a time when they really needed it so
thank you for being a show that infuses
us with the joy of life
complexities too you know because life
is messy oh is it messy and I love it so
much and the new season drops globally
on December 21st on Netflix thank you
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]